there's a lot going on in Rick and Morty
with its dimension spanning adventures
in Szechuan sauce and catch phrases like
Wubba lubba dub dub it's a complicated
show to jump on board with from the
get-go so to help newcomers and those
who want a refresher let's explain the
otherworldly story of Rick and Morty to
be clear we're going to spoil everything
that's happened on the show so far so
there's your warning Oh spoilers
let's start with Rick Sanchez the
smartest man in the universe
Rick only recently reunited with his
adult daughter Beth Smith because she's
desperate for her dad's approval and
traumatized by him leaving in the first
place Beth welcomes his dysfunction into
the home she shares with her husband
Jerry a perpetually down-on-his-luck
loser who Rick hates Beth and Jerry have
two kids their daughter summer is in
many ways the average American teenage
girl she's worried about fashion her
friends and the various boy she likes at
her school what sets her apart from the
rest of her peers is how utterly unfazed
she seems to be by her parents failing
marriage and her Grandpa's high-risk
space adventures then there's Morty the
youngest in the family and Rick's
closest ally in his maddening adventures
prior to Rick's arrival Morty was a
troubled kid charting well below average
at his school a big reason why could
have to do with his crippling crush on a
girl named Jessica after Rick shows up
well none of that really changes but
Morty's life becomes very different
[Music]
wicked Morty forever and forever a
hundred years Rick and Morty some things
Morty around the first episode of the
series opens with Morty falling asleep
at the breakfast table after a drunk
Rick kept him up the night before with
threats to restart humanity with the
neutrino bomb yes that's the first thing
that happens Morty's parents worried
that Rick's high jinks with their son
are having unhealthy effects on him
particularly at school where they
acknowledge he may be developing slower
than his peers but Rick nonetheless
takes Morty out of school for an
adventure using his famous portal gun a
handheld device that allows him to
travel anywhere in space it can also
travel between infinite alternate
dimensions so while Rick can't travel in
time he can travel in different
timelines the show doesn't shy away from
the impact that traveling multiple
universes can have on even a super
geniuses mind it's revealed in episode 1
that it's hard for Rick to relate to
other people even as family because he
knows that the best and worst versions
of himself exist in infinite realities
the adventure goes horribly and it's
pretty traumatic for Morty who breaks
his legs and is forced to kill some
alien officers when it's over Rick
explains to Beth and Jerry that
travelling with him is the only way a
mind like Morty is going to catch up in
school of course that's not really true
holy cow Rick I didn't know hanging out
with you is making me smarter
full disclosure Morty it's not things go
terribly awry when Morty's crush on
Jessica becomes overwhelming he asked
his grandpa Rick if there's anything he
can create to make her like him although
Rick thinks his grandson is being creepy
he relents and gives Morty a love potion
of sorts but there's a drawback it's
contagious
Morty uses it on Jessica at the annual
flu season dance and it causes her to
spread an uncontrollable virus that
makes people aggressively in love with
Morty regardless of gender age or status
so Rick makes two attempts to produce an
airborne cure that not only makes it
spread globally but it mutates everyone
into hideous monsters that Rick
offhandedly labels Cronenberg's to
escape the escalating problem Rick
transports Morty and himself to a nearly
identical version of that timeline where
a parallel Rick and Morty both die in a
freak accident after that universes Rick
successfully solves the Cronenberg
problem together our heroes bury their
alternates corpses and rejoin this
alternate version of earth as if
nothing ever happened the answer is
don't think about it it's not like we
could do this every week anyways we get
three or four more of these tops the
Smith family has a lot of problems with
deep-seated resentments and Beth and
Jerry's marriage everything gets thrust
out into the open in Episode eight after
Rick gets frustrated at the bachelor and
upgrades the family cable box with wacky
channels from every possible dimension
while that leads to some very funny
alternate universe ads it's two brothers
and a and and they're gonna it's called
two brothers two brothers
it's just culture it also gives them a
glimpse into a world in which Jerry is
as famous as Tom Hanks
so I'll Rick and Morty sit on the couch
and watch trashy TV the rest of the
family decides to watch what alternate
seemingly happier versions of themselves
are doing Jerry and Beth discovered they
could have lived their personal dreams
in a world where they never had summer
while her parents wonder if their
continued marriage is a good thing for
anyone involved summer prepares to run
away from home having seen what her
existence does to them however Morty
stops her by sharing the fact that he's
her brother from a different reality her
existence like everything else is
neither a burden nor an asset it all
means nothing meanwhile Beth and Jerry
see themselves get back together in
their otherwise happy alternate timeline
and agreed to stay married a group of
Rick's from various universes and their
Morty's have gotten together to form a
society on a floating space Citadel our
Rick from universe c-137 isn't too much
of a joiner and he has rebuffed their
invitation but the Council of Rick's
comes calling when a Rick from another
dimension framed c-137 Rick for the
deaths of 27 alternate dimension Rick's
c-137 is arrested by the council for the
crimes and subsequently escapes
that's when Morty learns at Rick's
genius gives off a very distinct
brainwave pattern that makes it easy for
his various enemies to track him
traveling with Morty is a selfish
necessity for Rick
Rick's have a very distinctive and
traceable brain wave due to our genius
the best way to hide from an enemy's
radar is to stand near someone with
complimentary brainwaves that make ours
invisible while c-137 morty stages a
morty rebellion in light of that
revelation our Rick learns about the
frame-up and evil Rick is killed the
council then learns that evil Rick's
Morty was controlling the situation the
whole time c-137 Rick and Morty aren't
privy to that information
and evil Morty vanishes into the crowd
at the Citadel the Galactic Federation
comprised of more than 6,000 earth-like
planets is run predominantly by a bug
like alien race known as the Grom flaw
mites the Federation is a beacon of
order civilization and stability within
the universe obviously these principles
are grading to the rebellious Rick along
with his friends birdperson and squanchy
birdperson invites dismissed to his
wedding to summer sprang Tammy there he
reveals that he and Rick bought many
battles against the Federation and
committed many atrocities for which
they're wanted the Galactic government
considers us terrorists it's unwise of
me to share these details but I've
become inebriated and that's when the
Federation launches an attack
orchestrated by Tammy a deep-cover
Federation operative who kills
birdperson earth is no longer safe the
smiths go into hiding and Rick learns
just how much of a burden he spent to
his relatives under the guise of going
out for ice cream
Rick reveals his location to the
Federation on the condition that his
family will be allowed to go free the
Smiths are picked up on their hiding
place and return to Earth which is
thriving under Federation rule meanwhile
Rick is seen being locked away in the
bowels of the grande blue mites most
secure prison with nothing but time
working against him as they tried to
unlock his secrets
Rick finds himself inside a Grom flight
simulation generator as they attempt to
trick him into giving up the secret to
interdimensional travel the machine uses
Rick's memories against him and allows
the grumble mites to trigger thoughts
about how he invented his portal gun
instead of falling for their trick
Rick flexes his genius and fabricates an
origin story in place of an actual
memory thus hacking the machine and
allowing him to switch bodies with his
interrogator meanwhile Morty and summer
are finding a Rick list Federation
controlled earth too much to bear
summer digs up the dead Rick from the
Cronenberg debacle and uses his portal
gun which the Council of Rick's Flags
when Morty and summer explained that
their Rick has been arrested by the
Federation the council dispatches
soldiers to assassinate rick c-137 once
and for all
Rick switches bodies again with one of
the assassin Rick's and uses him to
infiltrate the Citadel he teleports the
Citadel into the same space as the
Federation prison launching a massive
battle between his two greatest enemies
he then reunites with Morty and summer
before executing the final part of a
plan that began when he turned
himself in after the wedding Rick hacks
into the Federation mainframe and
reduces the value of its currency to
zero chaos ensues and the Federation
falls within minutes defeated they leave
her then Rick returns home safely
Rick toppling the Federation has an
extremely negative impact on Jerry who
is thriving under a government that
valued thoughtlessness he realizes that
things have gotten much worse for him
now that rick has replaced him as the
family patriarch and makes a him or me
ultimatum it doesn't work
Jerry's going to spend some time
divorced
having just defeated the gronckle mites
and the council an arrogant Rick
confesses to Morty that this was his
grand plan all along Jerry in the
Federation wanted him gone so he made
them both go away
Jerry tries his best to not let his
depression get the better of him
including a messy rebound with an Alien
Hunter his steady meets on an
interdimensional dating app Beth
meanwhile can't seem to find her place
and her now fully broken family the
Citadel is not some perfect utopia and
has a sizable class and wealth divide
among the various Rick's and Morty's
that live there some versions of Rick
wind up doing menial tasks to keep the
Citadel running and some Morty's take a
dark turn toward crime while others
thrive without Rick's evil Morty has
been consolidating his power during the
rebuilding of the Citadel following the
battle with the Federation adopting a
working class hero persona that's made
him popular enough to run for president
although his candidacy is first
considered a joke due to the fact that
he's a morty evil morty gives an
impassioned speech about the class
divide in the citadel the division i see
is between the Rick's and Morty's that
like the Citadel divided and the rest of
us with that speed she becomes the first
democratically-elected morty president
however when it's revealed that a shadow
government exists within the council
evil morty promptly dispatches all of
the Rick's that threaten his power evil
Morty Moore's the Council of Rick's into
a dictatorship c-137 Rick's propensity
to see past traditional labels and power
dynamics puts him directly in the
crosshairs of the President of the
United States always one for an
adventure Rick routinely takes calls
from the most powerful man in the world
because he feels like Morty is enamored
with the idea of helping his country
however when even morty realizes they
basically become the Prez
intergalactic exterminators they bail on
a mission from the commander-in-chief in
favor of playing Minecraft notify the
president what do I tell him tell him
the truth
tell him Rick and Morty just blew off
America the president is desperate to
prove that he doesn't need Rick and
Morty but he keeps coming up short and
becomes increasingly erratic as he
constantly loses the wreck things
devolve into a literal fistfight with
the president that ends in a draw when
rick has family issues arise realizing
that staying with this c-137 family on
earth means he can't be a threat to
national security
Rick tricks the president into thinking
things are good between that in light of
Beth's personal struggles Rick offers
her the chance to travel the galaxy on
her own terms while a clone version of
herself stays behind to take care of the
family you could be gone a day a week or
the rest of your life with zero
consequences the moment you decided to
come back I flip a switch and the clones
job is done unfortunately this doesn't
help with their identity crisis as now
she has no clue if she's physically
herself or clone without meaning to Rick
pushes Beth right back to Jerry because
he's the only one that can help her
understand if she's really herself
Jerry uses the opportunity to talk about
the first time that he told her he loved
her realizing that his unconditional
love is part of who she is she takes him
back in endeavors to rebuild her family
without the manipulative influence of
Rick the only way to do that however is
to go into hiding unfortunately none of
the Smiths are smart enough to hide from
Rick who arrives at their hideout ready
to outright kill Jerry
but Beth puts her foot down with her
father for the first time Rick tries to
explain that best feelings are
meaningless in a limitless multiverse
but he relents and yields his position
as the patriarch to stay with his family
real family now in many ways things will
be like season 1 but more streamlined
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]